so we've got this up our sleeve now
right i want to keep digging into this
and introduce a bit more notation for
you
this is a very long way to write this
out simply because there are so many
terms there
you can see mathematicians are always
after patterns
every term in this series follows
exactly the same patterns incredibly
predictable
right in fact you can say for any given
term it's it's format
right the way it's laid out looks like
this
um the earth
term okay
which term is the r term it's going to
be
n c r and then the power of x
is going to match that r number down the
bottom right and that will be the
r term which does mean that this is the
zeroth term okay so watch out for that
but
i think it's much more helpful to
understand that as a zeroth term in the
first term
now if that's what each term
individually is
then this whole series is just the sum
of all of these guys
right so i'm going to write that like
this right 1
plus x to the n that's the whole thing
that's equal to now i want you to draw a
big greek letter for me
it looks like this this is called sigma
it's a great letter it's one of my
favorites it just looks cool when you
draw it
okay sigma let me make you
uh a quick warning okay
that's what sigma should look like it's
a capital sigma by the way lower case
sigma looks completely different
a lot of people draw their sigma like
this
and my heart dies a little time every
time someone draws a sigma
like that okay um please don't draw your
sigma like that in this classroom
i will throw a sharp implement at you um
will i deduct marks off you
probably not but just draw it properly
okay
that's that's what that's what sigma
looks like not like that
okay now this sigma notation it's sigma
for
sum s for sum okay so i'm summing i'm
adding up all of these terms right i'm
adding up terms that all look like this
right so i'm going to say i'm going to
start
right i want r i want to start with
the first term has an r value of 0.
right and it's a very first term what
value did the last
r term have i start at zero
there and then i end at
n right
okay that's my last my last value there
for r
r is the number that's changing all the
way through okay
so i'm adding up all of these terms
right so this is a way for me to write
this
but i'm kind of like ah there's so much
repetition right they all look the same
they all look exactly like this
so this is my shortcut way of saying it
i would read this as
1 plus x to the n is equal to the sum
from 0 to n
of ncr x to the r i'll say that again
okay 1 plus x to the n
is equal to the sum from 0
to n so they're kind of like a starting
point and ending point
of this thing and we call this another
name for it is
this is the general term it's called
general because
it's generally what they're all equal to
okay
that's the general term
okay now being that we've got all this
fancy new notation
and we also have pascal's triangle on
the board okay
i'm going to use this notation to
express some of the properties that
we've already noticed
in pascal's triangle and this will start
to dig at some of the why questions i
asked
yesterday and left you you know sitting
with i'll answer one of them today but
only one okay
see how we go so what are some
properties that you see
okay i can see three very simple basic
properties
the first property i see is that all of
these numbers on the outside
they're all on the edges they're all one
you don't need any thinking to notice
that they're all one
so how would i write that down how would
i articulate that
hmm yeah and last
like first and last coefficient of each
of the terms
is one okay all right let me go with
that idea we started with
first and last and we said coefficients
right so
these guys these guys are our
coefficients yep
so how do i say first coefficient and
last coefficient because i have language
for this now that i can use to describe
this stars
good okay there you go my notation
allows me to just
write it not just say you know when i
put it
rather than say oh you know this fret
that's about a third the way up and that
other fret that's about half the way
down
kinda ish a little bit in i actually
have precise language for this
okay so i can say here's number one
right
i'll put this i'll put this right here
in the middle here
this is property number one okay out of
pascal's triangle
that n c zero and n
c n they're both and always equal to one
no matter what n you throw in there
okay good so you've got the one idea uh
another basic copy that we've already
referred to this morning is that
the whole thing is symmetrical once
you've got one half of haskell's
triangle
you've got the other half okay so how
could i
articulate that this is a bit trickier
okay
for instance let's have a look here uh
we looked at these two right so
and we've got 11 c6 and they're equal
you can see it on the board right but
they're not the only ones that are equal
let's pick out another pair say 11c2
should be equal to
11 c 9. right 11 c9
and you could pick out another pair for
instance without writing it down
11c3 is going to be equal to 11c 8.
i have some examples right you got this
one
you got this one what's the pattern
yeah good these subscripts the r which
term you're going along
these guys should always add up to this
guy right
these guys did this guy these guys can
you see it okay
so for instance if i would say all right
for any term
any term along there right it's going to
be equal to its
opposite one in the same row
so it's clearly going to be in the nth
row what would this number down here be
yeah n minus r can you see it let me
replace them for you right
this 8 is really 11
minus 3. that's what it really is okay
and this is
this 9 is really 11 minus minus 2
right another way of thinking about this
is what's 2
right i'm gonna give you a really weird
way of saying two
two is zero plus two right so you start
at this end and you go that way
two and then this is eleven minus two
you start at this end
and you go two right so so that's what
this is referring to not just numbers
this is symmetry in here
one last property and we're going to
quickly prove it okay um
it's one of the properties that i gave
you yesterday and you were like what
okay we said that this row it adds up to
one and this row adds up to 2
4 8 16 32 and so on
okay so this is kind of like the the sum
property of every row
so before we prove it
how do we state it how do we state it
i'm probably gonna need more room that's
in my box
okay so two caravan right that's the sum
of yeah it's the sum of all of these
coefficients
isn't it right not not the x's forget
about those guys it's just the numbers
right
so i'm going to write that as 2 to the n
is the
sum from r
0 all the way up to n of
just the coefficients